[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لقد خرجت للتو من الحمام
وفجأة انهارت الجدران ،
أعني انهيار السقف
وفجرتني على الأرض وحصرت الزاوية أسفل
طاولة غرفة الطعام حيث كان كل شيء على ما يرام
تحطمت من
حولي وكنت أحاول الوصول إلى زوجتي
بالطرف الآخر من المنزل ،
أخيرًا زحفت من إحدى النوافذ
وجعلتها تدور حول المقدمة
، ثم كان قسم الإطفاء
هنا وغطيت بالسيارات البيضاء الدماء
سيارتي
ما  بعد ذلك ، لم
نحصل على أي
شيء مجانًا
، لم أكن أنام ، لقد استلقيت للتو على
سريري ،
لكنني سمعت باستمرار
إنذارات الحريق وأجهزة الإنذار ضد السرقة تنطلق
في الحي
واستمريت في سماع ضوضاء وضوضاء
وحطام على أمل أن تكون قطتي التي
كان السقف بها  ذهبت
أه الجدران تتساقط
أه بالنسبة لي إنها خسارة كاملة بالنسبة لي ،
أنت تعلم أنني لا أعرف أنه يبدو أنه
يعتقد أنه قد يكون قابلاً للإصلاح ولست أنا
لا أراه
أنت